listen you can't lift that weight at
some point in your life you're going to
die you are sick your marriage has
problems you're dropping the ball at
certain aspects of your job or as a
father as a husband you've made promises
to yourself that you haven't kept that's
reality and to tell yourself that
failure is not an option is to
consistently live in a state of denying
reality it's delusional by definition my
clubs for closers so something I do want
to talk about this before but I think
it's more relevant than ever is this
mantra that I hear a lot and I think
it's incredibly use word toxic now these
terms have been co-opted but it really
is toxic the idea that failure is not an
option here that a lot of failure is not
an option
um well right now this is an example
we're talking about this we're fighting
Facebook Disney ABC the Academy I don't
even know if they are Disney ABC
internal battles of course we have
battles well-known battles with YouTube
this has been going on for a long time
and it is I want to say sometimes it
feels insurmountable and I'll come back
to this sometimes of course I want to
pack up and go home
it has been a very very trying week and
using only no Hopper's been sick he's
been doing very well thank you so much
for your comments I'm not at the top of
my health game right now but let me just
tell you something
failure is absolutely an option I know
that I've talked about this a lot but
I'd like to put a finer point on it a
good example recently I was watching
television and I saw a commercial that
mentioned Huntsville Alabama you know
rocket City USA and the man in the
commercial was talking about how failure
failure was not an option now here's the
thing I understand where he's coming
from I'm not saying that rocket
scientists NASA whoever this guy was is
being dishonest he's effectively trying
to express the importance of the task
and the severity of the failure therein
okay someone could die something could
blow up I appreciate the accountability
being expressed in the sentiment so do
not get mad don't say you're attacking
NASA that's not what I'm doing here but
I disagree with the phrase and I think
it's one we need to do away with I
certainly would encourage you to do away
with it in your personal life mainly
because I see so many people use it as a
personal mantra failure is not an option
failures not an option failure is not an
option
kind of like and I think I can I think I
can I think I can but I've talked about
this before my good friend Sheila's
talked about this before
failure is always an option in fact it's
often the easiest and most readily
available option that doesn't mean that
the consequences are easier desirable
but the action of failing is always
there every step of the way it's more
apparent to me now than ever as we
talked about on this show your guiding
light above all else I hate this sounds
cheesy but it needs to be truth and so I
don't think that ever denying reality is
the most productive round I just don't
believe it I know that it's been helpful
for me and I think would behoove many of
you to consider dropping the mindset for
a more accurate one failure is always an
option don't tell yourself it's not if
you tell yourself it's not you're
effectively denying this huge this
ribbon this milky way this this cosmic
belt of reality sometimes it's the
biggest cosmic belt of reality in your
path certainly the most looming let me
give you an example let's say you're
driving down a freeway there's a major
roadblock let's say a five car pileup
does it help you to say there's no
pileup it's not even on the table or is
it more productive to see the pileup to
acknowledge it and to refuse to allow it
to impede your progress see the former
mindset that of telling yourself that
there is no roadblock failures not an
option leads to what what does it lead
to riding straight into that roadblock
the latter acknowledging it seeing the
roadblock including this data
incorporating the information into your
reality largely because it is reality
I'll come back to that in a second
living your truth it'll be more
productive it would lead to a solution
you know it's there but you don't want
to end up in that roadblock so you're
more likely to take a different route to
recalibrate to succeed why do we tell
ourselves this that failure is not an
option why do we consistently lie to
ourselves and why has it been accepted
as though it's I see it in the Christian
community as well as this sort of
self-help guru community which is more
productive okay let's just look at this
from a pragmatic point of view the
failure is not an option mantra or let's
just say let's we switched it to failure
is dis allowable I'd like to see more
people saying failure is dis allowable
as opposed to lying themselves saying
that failures not an option it may sound
trivial but one is a sound bite in one
is a way of life one it's a mantra okay
that sounds good on daytime talk shows
it sells self-help book
the others are very non sexy but
necessary mindset to deal with your own
shortcomings most importantly one is
dishonest and one is truthful
I'd say it's honestly it's even more
severe then then that in that one is
dishonest and arguably the most
destructive way possible and then it's
the kind of dishonesty in which you lie
to yourself but when your marriage
failure is not an option failures not an
option in your work failures not an
option failures not an option in your
physical training failures and an option
failures not an option only to find
yourself at some point when you've been
living with this mantra I don't know
it's a broken marriage possibly a
divorce losing your job or in the most
literal sense physical harm finding
yourself under a barbell by the way I
don't know what's happen with my wrist
it's not the power glove with what the
boy from Boy Meets World the brother the
old Fred Savage
wizard is it so bad by the way that's
why I believe that physical training is
so important a lot of people say oh
you're a meathead know sometimes
experiencing the most literal strain
possible tells you a lot about yourself
a lot about your place in this world and
how you interact with it so do me a
favor we do this every week and often
you tweet me or you send me messages and
it ends up on the mug Club life advice
segment did me a favor run this
experiment find out what your maximal
strength is at how much you can squat
deadlift hello hi I don't care how many
pull-ups you can do okay this is just an
experiment I'm not saying that how many
pull-ups you can do determines your
marital quality but just find something
that measures your maximal strength
write it down okay perform at once now I
want you to add 15% doesn't seem like a
ton right tell yourself failure is not
an option
repeated as many times as necessary
listen to your eat listen to your amp up
music get Slayer going I don't know what
you listen to nowadays I don't know if
Linkin Park is still a thing that's it
pissed me off in high school get
yourself to peak by any means possible
and try it pause this right now try it
add 15% did you succeed see that's why
the mantra of failure is not an option
is so harmful because it's all of us
lying to yourself all the while these
roadblocks keep piling up you will come
to that roadblock you will come to that
pileup it's there it's always there but
if you acknowledge it if you're honest
with yourself
you can prepare for it and you can
choose not always but often to disallow
failure so I want you to take that same
experiment okay
find out your maximal strength same as
before it could be a squad could be even
a number of pull-ups it just has to be
consistent with what you did before okay
now instead of performing it and then
adding 15 percent of amping yourself up
with failures not an option I want you
to take a different tack I want you to
acknowledge that that is your limitation
that going past it will lead to failure
keep that in the back of your mind okay
but don't reach it don't max out and
here's what I want you to do I want you
to not perform to failure but to chart a
course to improve it for example let's
say your max maximum squad is 300 pounds
consistently do let's call it 275 pounds
but gradually add every time I go to the
gym five pounds work hard work hard work
diligently but not to failure if you can
do 15 pull-ups only do 12 or 13 but
consistently and add one rep write it
down and then I want you to come back
and note when you surpass your previous
limit I guarantee you this is a promise
okay not an empty promise I guarantee
you that using that method you will
surpass it and you'll probably be
surprised by how quickly it happens now
this experiment here it's not about
lifting weights is to show you that one
way of doing things the failure is not
an option doesn't work you can try and
move that weight Shevin he even strain
all you want you will be no closer
0% closer to achieving growth than you
were when you started the other while
not sexy very workman like it's not a
show horse it's a Clydesdale will lead
to break through the break that you were
seeking in the first place it's a great
irony in life that these triumphant
these grandiose ways that we try to
achieve our breakthroughs they're
usually the ones that keep us from
achieving them because it's the
preparation that matters it's the
in-betweens like I've talked but it's
the unsexy measures we take when no one
is watching when the excitements worn
off and failure is always an option in
the back of our mind see if one the
failure is not an option is effectively
the false mantra of living your truth
that's why I think I hate it so much
whereas the decision to acknowledge
failure as an option but disallowing it
to determine your long-term
circumstances is the equivalent to
living in the truth I don't think
there's anything sillier than saying
this I'm speaking my truth
to hedge to say you could be a flyer
that's what you could be saying sorry
corner black Garrett has to hit the
sensor button I'm a little pissed off
this week I don't really care if let it
fly out I'll reset I'll recalibrate next
week because I realize failure with my
vocabulary is an option but what is
living your truth me if you're not
living in the truth there is absolute
truth and sometimes your truth and the
truth are incongruent as a matter of
fact I'd wager more often than not
because often the truth is really
uncomfortable but guess what the truth
is always there it's always there and if
your truth isn't the truth it's gonna
hit you like a brick in the face maybe
not today maybe not tomorrow sooner or
later the truth is coming from you I say
from you or for you I don't care that I
saw this bumper sticker show they were
climbing on a summit hell does that mean
what does it mean the truth is you have
limits I'm a rock no you're a human and
you're breakable we all are where people
live themselves on their sick how many
times you know these people are positive
speaking Booker I understand you don't
want to be a negative Nancy but you're
not sick and they cough up a lung listen
you can't lift that weight at some point
in your life you're going to die you are
sick your marriage has problems you're
dropping the ball at certain aspects of
your job or as a father as a husband
you've made promises to yourself that
you haven't kept that's reality and to
tell yourself that failure is not an
option is to consistently live in a
state of denying reality it's delusional
by definition right now to give you an
idea to tie this back into us and I
don't want this to just be about me we
were hit with four copyright claims in
the same day on the same show to try and
suppress it three have been defeated
they're just biding their time on the
fourth hoping that the Oscars will no
longer be relevant and that you don't
watch it when it's available please
prove them wrong we're currently
preparing for an epic legal war with
Facebook one that will test the
integrity and fortitude not only myself
but everyone on this team also you how
long will you stick it out how long will
you support us this week we had to miss
three shows to fight these battles
believe me that wasn't fun for us there
are
to be a few more weeks like that if this
goes to court how long are you in when
the dust has settled the excitement of
the initial war the battle cry has died
out when we're in the trenches rained on
covered in dirt waiting are you still
there because failure is always an
option I have to be honest with myself
right now failure is the most easy
readily available option I'm not a rock
I'm not a man without limits I'm a very
limited man who is fallible and
breakable it'd be a lot easier to fail
right now because rather than continuing
rather than reinvesting and creating for
the unheard majority of Americans you
the international fans out there know I
have a lot of Canadian Greek Orthodox
Pentel is just told me this I could
collect my marbles that I've gained thus
far right now and go home even more I'm
at a point right now where I know that
the failure of this program of this
movement of your movement right now is a
much more easy option today than it will
be once we're in this [ __ ] because
once we're in this fight we can't unring
that Bell unless we win
I can't recoup all the resources
finances creative energy and just life
energy that's been invested into it
failure is a much more easy option for
me to choose today than it would be
tomorrow or the next day or the next and
I know that and I struggle with it I
could a lie to you I struggle with it
all the time there are times where I
come really close to calling it and
packing it in deny that to a lot of
myself and to lie to you about it for
the sake of an interim kind of
inspirational soundbite would not only
be dishonest
it would cloud my judgement to the
decisions that I have to make for all of
us moving forward it would also be
little by the way the magnitude of what
you've done for me you the listeners of
your for us the truth is that you've
helped us build something so impactful
so important to such a multitude of
people that the walls are closing in
tempting us by providing the option of
failure that's where we are right now
failure is a would be a relief failure
is an option I'm not gonna lie to you I
go a step further and say not only an
option it's a very possible outcome
that's why it's at the front of my mind
I want it to be the front of yours
because then we're all in the same page
knowing that right now at this moment in
history we all have a decision to make
we can choose failure right now we can
choose easy
right now and it's available it's right
there we can choose relief we can choose
peace through failure right now or we
can choose to go through the hard door
and this may not be as inspirational it
may not sell as many books but I can
promise you this so long as you all of
you watching listening streaming choose
to go through those hard doorways those
thresholds meaning many doorway after
doorway after doorways so long as you
keep choosing to do that with us I
promise you so will I you tell me you in
comment let me know you're in I am to
the rest of you fill your hand you son
of a for everyone else
there's my club you like this video
subscribe to the channel or hit the
notification bell do it I'll wait a
second
do you hear that little ding it actually
did make a ding sound I just did it
would happen while my mouth was doing it
and you thought it was coming from your
computer so that's fun also there's some
videos playing in these boxes next to me
go watch those you might enjoy them you
might not you don't care